[Music]
cries of mourning for three migrant
teenagers who died of excessive heat
while crammed into the back of a
semi-trailer in san antonio texas last
month
their bodies arrived in the town of
marcos atexquilapan in the early hours
on wednesday
friends and family of the boys still
devastated over their deaths
amigos
we were close friends we played on a
soccer team and well the truth was they
were sincerely very humble people very
hard workers and fun to be around
the boys were all cousins
and were among a total of 53 migrants
who died in what has been described as
one of the deadliest cases of human
smuggling in recent memory
the mother of two of the victims yolanda
valencia says her sons had dreams of
finding a better life in the united
states
they wanted to build a house and start a
business not spend their lives making
shoes because it is tiring work here
there is work but it pays poorly things
go up in price but wages don't that's
why they went to look for a better life
while an investigation into the tragedy
continues mexico's president has renewed
calls for policy changes to regulate the
flow of migrants seeking work in the
united states
instead of that relationship that
perpetuates human rights violations
terror blessings and loss of human life
we should have a more orderly migratory
flow through temporary work visas
more than half of the victims have been
identified as mexican nationals
others are from honduras and guatemala
more repatriation flights of bodies to
their countries of origin are expected
to continue in the coming days
manuel rapalo al jazeera